you know this is a story that we we
talked about on the radio side
and on the surface when i see the report
from zach rosenblatt of nj.com citing an
unnamed source that it's unlikely nick
foles will return to the eagles as a
backup my first reaction was to be a
little snarky be a little mean spirited
and say well of course it's unlikely
zach you're not telling us anything we
don't know
if likely is more than 50 and unlikely
is is less than 50 yes it's unlikely
that nick foles will be the backup to
carson wentz in 2019
especially if the eagles apply the
franchise tag to nick foles at what will
roughly be 25 million dollars for a
one-year salary when you've got carson
wentz in the fourth year of his rookie
contract and his base salary this year
is south of 1 million
it will be
problematic to say the least if you have
nick foles as his backup at 25 million
sends kind of a weird message to the
locker room if that's what you end up
doing
but
the more i looked at rosenblatt's story
there's there's enough meat there that
maybe we can begin the process of
connecting dots
and predicting the falling of dominoes
and maybe can glean
something significant because
in addition to
the comment that it's unlikely foles
will be the backup to carson wentz
rosenblatt points out that foles
probably would be interested in playing
for the giants probably i put that in
quotes because it was in quotes in his
story probably interested in the giants
that tells me this is coming from falls
or someone close to foals and this idea
of rattling the sword
about the giants
it it makes me think you know because a
week ago i said hey if the eagles are
going to apply the franchise tag to nick
foles for the sole purpose of trading
him they're violating the cba because
you're not allowed to
tag a guy simply to trade him you have
to have a good faith intention to employ
him at the amount of the tag which means
if you're going to tag nick foles as the
philadelphia eagles you have to intend
to pay him 25 million dollars to be the
backup to carson wentz but you know what
i poked around a little bit about that i
didn't get the impression that the the
falls camp was all that upset about the
prospect of being tagged and now i see
this
claim that foles would probably be
interested in the giants
i kind of think maybe foles and his
agents are trying
to bait the eagles
into tagging falls well now why would
you want to do that it's always better
to not be tagged well
maybe
just maybe
and i know sometimes when we speculate
people get their noses out of joint but
that's kind of what we do it's kind of
where there's value in understanding
how things have happened in the past
where the pieces are aligned now and
where they may go from here
what if
the agents who represent nick foles have
already
gauged the market for his services that
happens all the time it's tampering for
the teams to engage in the gauging of
the market but there are ways to do it
that are very discreet
that are very informative that are
hypothetical if need be but there's a
way to find out and usually the scouting
combine is the point where the facade is
dropped and people blatantly engage in
tampering about guys who are due to
become free agents but we've had weeks
now since the eagles ended their season
and people are trying to figure out what
nick foles is going to do it isn't all
that difficult to find a way to have
communications with the general managers
or head coaches or others with
organizations that may or may not be
interested in nick falls
and
if nick foles agents are learning
that
no one really wants to pay more than 25
million dollars a year on a long-term
deal
maybe his better play is to get tagged
and to sign it immediately whether
you're the backup in philly or whether
you get traded to jacksonville or
wherever else to lock in that 25 million
may be the way to go because if you do
hit the open market maybe you're not
going to get the kind of money
that you think you're going to get and
and stats you know for i got to give you
credit stats
it doesn't happen often but you had a
good point
you had a good point i'm going to
reluctantly give you praise
you raised a question that needed to be
raised
how many teams really do want nick falls
the the seat in denver is going to be
occupied by joe flacco we know that and
we know that the broncos considered
falls and opted for flacco which doesn't
say much for falls when you've got a
team picking flacco over falls now one
of the factors was polls is going to
cost more money but it's going to cost
more money i don't know because who else
is out there now you've got the jaguars
right that's a clear potential
destination because of the president of
john d filippo but other than the
jaguars where are the seats miami
i i i g i mean i guess brian flores the
new coach of the dolphins who saw up
close what foals did to the patriots
in the super bowl just
a year and less than a month ago could
be intrigued but you know what i have a
feeling that bill belichick was facing
nick foles twice a year he'd cracked
that code pretty quickly and he'd have
extra motivation to do it after what
happened in super bowl 52 so and and
here's the other thing too
for all these other teams that need
quarterbacks the dolphins who are we
talking about we're not talking about
nick falls we're talking about kyle
murray
you've got an incoming crop of young
cheap quarterbacks and what did we see
last year we saw five quarterbacks
drafted in round one and how many of
them are bust based upon one year none
what is that now i'm not saying that
these five guys are destined for
greatness and pro bowls and and busts in
canton but
the fact that as we approach draft 2019
the fact that draft 2018
was five for five with first round
quarterbacks is that going to result
in more quarterbacks or fewer
quarterbacks than otherwise would be
picked in round one this year it's gonna
cause a run on quarterbacks it's cheaper
it's a trend that is working we know
it's a copycat league so kyler murray
dwayne haskins drew lock
if you're a team that needs a
quarterback
are you going to lock in
with nick falls now
at 25 million or more per year
or are you going
to wait and see what happens in the
draft
i i just i think that
there's a real good chance
that nick falls people
have had the conversations they've
gauged the market and they've realized
probably better off with the 25 million
via the franchise tag from the
philadelphia eagles
i i i just have a feeling based upon and
that's the thing when you look at the
report from zack rosenblatt of nj.com
and i'm trying to provide him a
compliment here uh i'll see if i can do
it successfully
the actual nuts and bolts i look at and
i say who cares
right
but you think about it
you take a step back
you don't want to miss the forest for
the trees i never really did understand
that but it sounds good you don't want
to miss the forest for the trees the
forest here
is that maybe nick foles knows
that there isn't going to be a land rush
for nick foles if he hits the market as
an unrestricted free agent so the
question becomes
in this game of chess
checkers and ultimately chicken
are the eagles going to let him hit the
open market for
fear
of the possibility
that he stays in the division do they
use the franchise tag that's why
it's significant that someone
close to folds is saying he probably
would be interested in the giants we
don't even know if the giants are
interested in him
right maybe pat schumer is more
interested in case keenum maybe it's
going to be the same end result
that if the giants end up with case
keenum well first of all they could just
stick with eli manning but assuming
they're moving on from manning it could
be kingdom versus falls and while
kingdom's only 18 million dollars falls
is 25.
yeah
the events of this week
i think are significant as it relates to
what the interest will be in nick foles
and how much money will be a bail
available for nick foles and and
no matter what you do
and i think back to
when kurt warner had his resurgence in
arizona he wasn't handed that job
kurt warner had his time as the
quarterback for the greatest show-offs
on turf then he had that stretch
when it fell apart in st louis he was
with the giants and he got benched for
eli manning and there was just a sense
does he really have it anymore right uh
there's kind of that same so with foals
it's different because we've seen recent
postseason performances that we say oh
wow maybe he's got something but he had
that great 2013 when he had 27 touchdown
passes and two interceptions and at one
point chip kelly the coach of the eagles
declared he'd be the starter for the
next thousand years
and
then it fell off
and it's hard to set aside
that image of nick foles as the
quarterback of the rams and yes we can
blame jeff fisher we can blame the
offensive coordinator we can blame
everyone but nick foles
but if you're talking about
looking at the body of work and coming
to the conclusion that this guy's going
to make more than 25 million dollars a
year
one year after
the vikings handed 28 million per year
on a three-year contract fully
guaranteed to kirk cousins
and considering that last year all those
rookies taken in round one have worked
out
i i could see
quite possibly
a conclusion coming
that
nick foles isn't worth 25 million a year
and it could be
that
foles and his agents want the eagles to
pull the trigger on the franchise test
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports